President Joe Biden made a visit to
Ukraine yesterday and it was a
completely reasonable visit it was the
indication that Joe Biden and his
security team aren't scared to go to
Kiev where there were air raid sirens in
the background of the visit with the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
and yet Republicans are absolutely
Furious some even border borderline
defending Vladimir Putin as Putin has
suspended the new start treaty the most
belligerent signal recently since the
invasion of Ukraine that he may indeed
be going in the direction of at least
considering the use of nuclear weapons
in this conflict and it is difficult to
know where to start but let's maybe
start with the statements from Vladimir
Putin the Associated Press reports
Russia suspends only remaining major
nuclear treaty with the U.S
Russian President Vladimir Putin
declared Tuesday that Moscow was
suspending its participation in the new
start treaty the last remaining nuclear
arms control pact with the United States
sharply upping the ante amid tensions
with Washington over the fighting in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin made the
statement during his state of the nation
address during which he also said Russia
should stand ready to resume nuclear
weapons tests if the U.S does so a move
that would end a global ban on nuclear
weapons tests in place since Cold War
times this is not a coincidence in terms
of its timing Joe Biden yesterday in
Ukraine and Putin today of course we're
adjusting for the time difference today
saying these things this is a very real
threat we now have the possibility of
China aiding Russia that is increasingly
in the background of the discussion and
the United States in the midst of that
trying to figure out and when I say that
I don't mean trying to figure out as if
the answer is obvious I don't mean like
Trump's trying to figure out how tariffs
work well we know how tariffs work we
are genuinely trying to see
what possible diplomatic paths forward
there are
while continuing to support Ukraine
militarily
as this is an aggression by Russia
although some on the right don't want to
accept that but meanwhile many
Republicans and we're not going to look
through every example because I don't
have three hours to just play these
clips for you Republicans criticizing
Joe Biden for um this trip to Ukraine
and remember that with a lot of these
things it's always we're going to
criticize no matter what Biden hasn't
gone to the Border Kamala hasn't gone to
the Border they go well they went late
and also to the wrong City On the Border
well but they went but no but that shows
they don't really care I thought not
going showed they didn't care well no
going but to the wrong place at the
wrong time also shows they don't care
they just want to criticize but it's
becoming increasingly pathetic and
concerning from the standpoint of do
these Republicans even hold as a
priority what's best for the United
States and our people here is Republican
Congresswoman Nancy mace saying you know
it was President's Day to go to Ukraine
instead of Ohio it it was President's
Day after all burned salad if you ask me
uh kind of an embarrassment on the world
stage and to be in Ukraine on
President's Day as was just mentioned
rather than going to Ohio where
Americans really are suffering on one of
the largest environmental disasters in
my lifetime at least it is an
embarrassment and this so I thought
Americans were primarily suffering Nancy
and Republicans
from high uh from inflation from high
energy prices and other sorts of
economic instability directly linked to
what's going on in Ukraine no now that's
not important because you have to say it
was wrong for Biden to go and instead he
should have gone to Ohio so now Ohio
becomes really where people are
suffering now of course they're they're
suffering elsewhere uh there's always
suffering elsewhere and Joe Biden's no
longer in the basement but he's in the
wrong place so that's bad as well why
didn't he go to the Border yesterday I
mean it's President's Day after all so
this is we've talked about this before
this is like running through a cancer
fundraiser and screaming what about
Parkinson's are you all ignored don't
you care about Parkinson's and then you
go to the Parkinson's fundraiser and you
say every last one of you should be
ashamed of yourselves that you're doing
nothing about AIDS do you know about
AIDS and you're talking about
Parkinson's this is always it's very
tired it's very low brow it's very
transparent but they can always do this
and they often do when they don't want
to have to praise the actions of a
Democrat Donald Trump also held an event
yesterday in Palm Beach we're going to
look at this event more extensively
later but there was one moment where
Donald Trump also same line criticized
Biden for going to Ukraine but not to
Ohio done in two years nobody's ever
seen anything like it and even now you
have a president going to Ukraine and
you have people in Ohio that are in
desperate need of help and I was very
proud to say that I announced I was
going to Ohio you know FEMA said we're
not going to give many he was proud of
himself about the announcement that he
made okay the Biden Administration said
we're not going to give him anything and
then I announced I'm going please sit
down yeah go ahead sir we'll be here for
a while what do we have to do
why do we have to yeah it's not like
Trump's running a campaign or anything
anyway so Trump also criticizing Biden
for going to Ukraine instead of Ohio and
then everybody's favorite uh traitorous
congresswoman Marjorie Trader green
tweeted quote Biden didn't go to East
Palestine Ohio on President's Day again
I don't know why it matters that it's
President's Day it's this very strange
thing Biden didn't go to East Palestine
Ohio on President's Day he went to
Ukraine a non-nato nation whose leader
is an actor I mean okay so our leader
for a while was just a real estate dude
and is apparently now commanding our
United States military to World War we
must impeach this America last fool
before it's too late so completely
unhinged and pathetic uh Biden should be
impeached because he went to Ukraine if
you can imagine something as absurd as
this so that's the latest we're going to
delve more deeply into the Putin nukes
stuff the Biden trip as it went beyond
Ukraine uh heading to Poland we're going
to talk about all of it as the week
continues let's now talk about
the train derailment imagine for a
second that you try logging into your
email account only to find that your
password was changed an hour ago and
then you get notifications of activity
from your bank and then your credit
cards that is what identity theft is
like and it's a horrible feeling and we
dealt with it at the show not that long
ago but now I have an app called Aura
which gives me much more peace of mind
our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when when you need them off
of devices go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below